(quiet music)
- Hi, my name is
Maggie McGrath.
I'm the Editor of "ForbesWomen,"
and today I'm here to tell you
about our 16th "Annual
Power Women Ranking."
It's our list of the world's
100 most powerful women
across business, media, entertainment,
technology, finance, and politics.
To report out our list of the
world's most powerful women,
the "ForbesWomen" team
combs through all the lists
that already exist here at "Forbes."
"The Forbes 400," "The
World's Billionaires" lists,
"Self-Made Women."
We have 13 billionaires on
this year's list, in fact.
We also look at the "Celeb 100,"
our list of the world's
highest paid entertainers.
Some of those women, like
Taylor Swift and Rihanna,
have made our "Power Women"
list because they influence fans
around the globe through their
music, their social media,
and in the case of Rihanna
with Fenty, their business.
Newcomers in the media
and entertainment space
also include Reese
Witherspoon and Ava Duvernay.
Both women have production companies
and are shaping the way
Americans consume stories,
particularly stories about
underrepresented communities,
about and by underrepresented communities,
which is hugely important,
as we head into 2020.
In prior years, when we've done
the "World's Most Powerful Women" list,
we've had leaders in South
America make the cover
of "Forbes" magazine.
Political unrest in the
region has led to a drop-off
of nearly all of those figures,
but in business this year,
there's been a resurgence.
We have on this year's list
making her debut Paula Santilli.
She is the head of PepsiCo Latin America,
a $7.4 billion business,
and we also have the new CFO of Petrobras,
one of the world's largest oil companies.
Both of these women were
appointed to their positions
in the spring and make their
debut on the list this year
and give Latin America a resurgence
on our "Power Women" list.
In Africa, we looked at heads of states
across every country in the continent.
What's hard is those GDPs don't measure up
to some of the other GDPs in the world,
so these women who also aren't
always popularly elected
have a little bit of a
harder time making the list.
We have the head of Ethiopia
on this year's list,
but a number of other ministers
of tourism and finance and economy
who are on our "Women to Watch" list,
which is a separate list that we have
as a web-only piece this year.
Coming in at number one
for the ninth year in a row
is German Chancellor Angela Merkel.
She runs what is Europe's
largest GDP, largest economy.
She has a huge impact on
the region and on the world.
She sits on the European Council,
which appoints women
like Christine Lagarde
who is number two on this year's list.
She runs the European Central Bank,
was appointed to this
position just this year
after running the
International Monetary Fund
for a number of years.
And Merkel also helps appoint women
like Ursula von der Leyen.
She is the new President
of the European Commission,
the EU's legislative arm,
and with that power, affects legislation
that hits 700 million people
and brings her to number four on the list.
The highest ranking American
woman is Nancy Pelosi.
She's number three on the list
and the US Speaker of the
House for the second time
in recent history.
She served as Speaker from 2007 to 2011
and was on the "Power List" back then.
Dropped off after she fell out of power
after the Democrats fell out of power,
but she is back on the list.
And she is second in
line for the Presidency,
is the highest ranking elected woman
in the United States right now
and leading impeachment
proceedings against the President.
So, one could say that her
influence at this moment in time
is higher than it's ever been before.
So, it's a really strong
return to the list
for Speaker Pelosi.
Elsewhere in the top ten,
we have Melinda Gates,
who is the Chair of the Bill
and Melinda Gates Foundation
and affecting huge amounts of philanthropy
with their work abroad and in the US,
focusing on girl's education
and health and wellness.
Some notable movements
include Queen Elizabeth.
I talked to scholars and economists
about whether or not the
Queen is actually powerful,
and opinions range, let me tell you.
Last year, the Queen was
number 23 on the list.
This year, she's number 40.
I think this is reflected
by dint of her giving
some of her patronages and charities
to her sons and her daughters-in-law.
We still think the Queen
is a historic figure
in the world and in politics
and a very important lady,
but as she is 93, it does appear
like she's ready to
transition some of her powers
to the King in Waiting, Prince Charles.
Another notable newcomer this year
is Greta Thunberg, the Swedish
climate change activist
who is just 16, spoke at the
UN General Assembly this year
and sparked millions of people
to pour into the streets
to protest against
inaction on climate change.
She is number 100 on this year's list.
Our methodology does prioritize
assets under management,
company, market cap, revenue, country GDP.
Greta has none of these things,
but what she does have is
social media and influence.
She had more news clips about her
than almost any other woman on the list,
other than Angela Merkel and Nancy Pelosi.
So, she is a newcomer
and showing how power
can go beyond just money and market cap.
2017 was the year of Me Too and Time's Up,
and 2018 seemed to me the
year of fallout from that,
a lot of grappling with the revelations
that had occurred the year before.
2019 from my reporting seems
to be the year of action,
albeit slow action, maybe
shifts is the better word,
but you have the appointment of women
like Christine Lagarde
and Ursula von der Leyen.
You see funds like All Raise
trying to get more money
in the hands of female entrepreneurs.
Change is happening.
It's happening slowly, but
the women on the "Power List"
are using their power to
lift up the next generation
and to create gender parity for all.